[Musique]
mais
pardonne moi mon père car je vais pêcher
[Musique]
o'shea
qu'est-ce qui vient pour
sauf tout
[Musique]
non
comment vas tu es l'agent robinson aussi
bien que possible monsieur vous allez
bien ciena je suis l'inspecteur zain
désolé de vous déranger mais j'attendais
de pouvoir vous parler
j'ai pensé qu'elle pourrait vous plaire
vous avez besoin d'autre chose
vous pouvez parler
oui
comment vous vous sentez
je me sens pas trop mal
il me parlait exactement comme ça c'est
à dire
comme vous le faites comme si vous étiez
mon meilleur ami écoutez je sais que ça
vous est pénible de parler de ça mais
pour le bien des autres
je vais devoir vous poser quelques
questions je sais que vous n'en êtes pas
encore remise mais j'ai besoin de savoir
ce qui vous est arrivé à vous et à vos
amis là-bas et certaines choses qui ne
sont pas claires c'est lui
tout va bien sieda je suis conscient que
c'est très dur mais vous pouvez raconter
et j'ai besoin de notre bière à
l'arrière et cd venir à moi à l'essai je
parle avec annette et c'est là quoi
c'est pas mon truc et était majeur au
moment où tu fait juste semblant fichez
lui la paix les gars et veut pas de
bière si tu connais le proverbe
et c'est tout au moins une fois sauf le
curling et pc avec un lama a c'est ce
jeu blizzard sur glace qu'on joue
beaucoup au canada c'est ce que c'est
que le curling c'est pas ça que je
réagissais alors que si t'as pas compris
rien je réagissais seulement à nant rien
s mais chad
tu
eh ben tu as trouvé cette glacière pour
transport d'organes il était il avait
été laissé dans le véhicule
oui bien sûr n'en seriez y avait des
trucs habituels il y avait dedans une
paire de rein vainqueur est aussi un
petit morceau d'intestin on a compris
c'est bon tu es gamin tout ce que vous
pouvez être qu alors
[Musique]
je te le balancer aux chiottes pour vous
si vous voulez mais personne n'y verra
rien
et vos amis là comment vous les avez
connus
[Musique]
allez donne moi quelque chose de bien
avec les vas-y vas-y howie y est
mais qu'a fait moins de bruit non non tu
comprends pas c'est pourquoi vous allez
tous plongés mr ouai c'est la vérité
vous êtes foutus thein sein
ok c'est moi tu veux faire plonger un
[ __ ]
à toi tu dis ok je m'incline japon draps
on en est seulement la première donne ta
pas que toi j'ai une main tout ce qui
est pourri et je le sais qu'il ya encore
plus pourri dans le coin un johnny à
faire voir qu'est ce que tu as là je
suis ou et le full l'emportent sur le
brelan d'as c'est pas du tout ce que tu
crois
vous êtes malade il avait froid ouais
c'est vrai alors on a vous n'avez pas re
mettez le en place qu'est-ce que vous le
retrouviez à sega il était cool hockey
contentez vous en
et je suppose que vos amis ne l'avez
jamais vu
non
laissez le venir à moi les s'est levé
[Musique]
dernière occasion de faire le plein elle
est là depuis combien de temps cette
station depuis bien avant que le
grand-père de scott ne fouille
l'intimité de sa grand mère grand père a
dû d'abord s'occuper de ta grand mère
regardez moi ces tracteurs on dirait
qu'ils on s'entend mais on dirait que le
bâtiment va tomber en ruines d'une
seconde à venir dès ce type là dehors il
a l'air vraiment arrêts ça va être chaud
les gars aient les mecs rester cool mon
oncle connaît tout le monde dans le coin
je serais toi j'aimerais pas une chose
simple
elle a raison charmant aussi carstenz
les salles intérieures stoppé alors tout
le monde si dignement
ronnie ne toucher à rien de ça je n'ai
regardé si celle-là fonctionner pourquoi
tu lis le régisseur star pour la couleur
locale
mexico qu'est-ce que vous êtes fait au
bras j'ai juste eu un accident
travaillons sur les frais d'un client je
vais jeter un oeil scott
qu'est ce que tu veux contribuer à
l'écosystème
s'est infectée way to cook les toilettes
attendez une seconde
non car sa disparition de deux vaches un
fermier du coin a déclaré hier matin à
la police qu'une de ces noms dont deux
robes deux de ses vaches manquait à
l'appel
ok mais pas cette fois par jour je
devais gagner à séville a quitté le
shérif local
j'ai doublé presque merci d rien merci
beaucoup je suis fait je peux faire
quelque chose pour vous je crois que oui
vous pouvez remplir cette carte comme ça
nous serons quittes une carte de donneur
d'organes
remplissez la et glisser là dans votre
portefeuille ça peut sauver une vie
attendez ça c'est pour votre coach on y
va merci derrière banderoles on arrive
le nahd
on en a pour combien de temps jusqu'à la
cabane je dirais la moitié d'une heure
environ la moitié d'une heure la moitié
du lem démord pas ce que voient déjà le
bout du monde là bas et ensuite il faut
tourner à gauche et après on l ait
choisi des marges temps prix fait ça
pour moi saloperie de ma fille me fait
chier chien
quelque chose dont vous avez envie de
parler
éventuellement
reprenons nous en étions arrivés
d'accord ok
la cabane
c'était l'idée qui
[Musique]
je croyais que vous alliez arrêter ce
jeu débile sionneau rends toi une chose
c'est la studette red card princesse ça
n'a rien de drôle les mecs ballon ciena
c'est pas un drame
sinon
ici elle a fait un arrêt cardiaque ou un
truc du genre on devrait peut-être
l'emmener à l'hôpital
on est dans un hôpital abrutis sienna et
syna ça va c'était pour rigoler je suis
vraiment désolé c'était une blague
stupide on est tous désolés et le cadart
un mes copains je m'appelle jake désolé
vous n'êtes qu'une bande d'enfoirés de
première ouais ouais t'as raison
on pensait pas que ça te dit elle
qu'elle trouve apparemment j'ai pas fini
de vous surprendre
écoute
c'est le moment de l'année où on prend
le large pour recharger nos batteries et
on va tous chez mon grand père dans son
pavillon de chasse c'est plutôt sympa et
tranquille comme endroit vient avec nous
sinon ça nous donnera l'occasion nous
racheter qui vous dit que vous pourrez
jamais vous rachetez c'était son idée
c'était son idée c'est bien sûr toujours
la faute des noirs je voulais pas dire
je sais s'il et je suis sûr que vos amis
le savaient aussi ce qui leur est arrivé
n'a rien à voir avec vous le problème
c'est que vous allez devoir vivre en
essayant de vous en convaincre et prier
dieu d'y arriver
la kabbale
ses somptueux
c'est pas une cabane c'est carrément un
château et qui a jamais parlé d'une
cabane c'est vrai personne n'a dit
cabane peut-être mais pavillon de chasse
ça veut pas dire non plus château
renaissance
on ne sait pas n'importe quel château
c'est le château du roi
oui moi aussi qui reste elle attendait
ya là j'ai envie d'y aller vous venez je
suis partant alors on y va
yep moi sortir oui moi aussi je veux
descendre
allez tout le monde dehors ça va être le
pied du calme et on attend dé moi il n'y
avait que jason pour tomber sur le sol
plus brouillés qu'il y ait de ce superbe
quoi tu sais que tu vas rester marquée
avec moi t'inquiète les filles raffolent
des six catherine moins bien sûr c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que frankenstein
c'est un peuple en 2009 kazan et il
n'oublie pas l'horrible bossu qui se
tapait la gitane sa chèvre et djallit et
qu'on remonte ton dernier vaccin
antitétanique peu inquiète il va pas que
moore nécessiterait quelques points de
suture
le nouveau est qualifié pour en faire ok
je vais faire ça doit être simplissime
je vais stériliser un peu laissé tomber
scott
à nous deux va s'en occuper ok vous vous
occupez de la chirurgie et moi je
m'occupe déficit ok ok tirer à pile ou
face
j'ai une pièce si vous voulez je vais
chercher le kit masi oui vous n'avez pas
confiance en moi
aucune confiance ça va aller
jean mary
qu'est ce qui nous arrive et qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour vous faites le
plein ja rule
je croirais à grand central station
aujourd'hui
on ne fume pas ici mais j'irai
j'oubliais
est ce que vous auriez vu un 4/4 grippe
a c'est par ici les gens qui passent par
ici
oui je vois ça
[Musique]
jay fra 54 dollar cochise
un travail docteur merci docteur quel
magnifique poitrine docteur vous désirez
la caresser un peu docteur au très
volontiers nos terres
tu as déjà coûté ton propre sans rené
ils sont là que je les ai entendus
entendu dire qu'ils allaient au lac
c'est là qu'ils sont c'est là qu'ils
sont je vous dis que c'est là qu'ils
sont allés
je sais rené
je vais te faire cadeau de ceux ci et en
échange tu vas me donner un élément à
toi quoi quand le
maintenant comme moi les morts dont tu
peux te passer pour vivre rené tout va
bien
tout va bien
tarhoni tout va bien tout va bien dit le
aller qui le renie dis le à tout se
passera bien
car ils tuent leur lit 12
très bien
[Musique]
il passera bien arrêter tout pas très
bien ronny dit le tout va sera mien
tout passe ratée
non
d
tu es là
10le et
[Musique]
oh là là pour toi et encore pour toi et
en faire part
oui c'est cool c'est comment scott non
m'appelle une autre non big date et ma
belle peut-être que je réduis à doctor
et si on jouait au docteur justement
avec un max de bénéfices seulement si
c'est toi la patiente ma belle oui je
vais être bien raconte moi ce que tu
manges tu aurais vu bazire pas tout
restent les plus forts les deux façons
de recherche rien vous vous en sortez
pas mal celui ci est venu porter malheur
c'est très beau racing station
nous aimerions voir scott warren nous
devons lui parler
si d'ailleurs qu'à vous tous
[Applaudissements]
scott
ai je besoin d aide
qui est dans le couloir c'est bon les
gars une [ __ ] me refait jamais ce
coup-là s'te plaît il ya déflecteur il
demande à nous voir tous tu veux mais
pourquoi tu m'attends 1
oui quoi
j'étais justement en pleine expérience
je voulais voir si vite
hello les gars vous êtes scott warren
vous avez utilisé votre carte de crédit
hier après midi à la station service
moon ouais
rolly moon
quelle horreur
oui quelqu'un l'a découpé en morceaux
comme une dinde de noël
shannon
vous êtes qui vous dis moi juste une
chose
quel est ton groupe sanguin jason
devrait arriver alors comme ça vous êtes
étudiant vous remettez oui comme ben
vous allez devenir des docteurs oui on
l'espère en tout cas
ouais c'est ce que vise ce qu'ils font
en médecine comme étude de quoi est ce
qu'il s'agit
madame il faut que je vous dise que le
tueur à utiliser un scalpel sur monsieur
brou et sac ou plutôt pas mal
écoutez nous n'avons aucune idée de ce
qui s'est passé si c'est ce que vous
vouliez savoir faucon fils
ils veulent un premier rapport à 10
heures on reviendra alors ne disparaît
c'est pas dans la nature
oui jason
c'est pas le genre de jay z je suis sûr
qu'il n'aurait pas filer sans en toucher
un mot
toujours rien non j'ai regardé partout
mais je le trouve nulle part c'est pas
son style
il se passe quelque chose d'anormal ok
pas de panique il faut qu'on réfléchisse
calme réfléchir calmement réfléchir à
quoi exactement
je vous rappelle qu'on l'a cherché
partout et qu'on n'a rien trouvé ils
fous nous c'est une blague qu'il nous
faille choses si ce scot et celles
restées sérieux une seconde étant dit il
faut qu'on trouve une stratégie ouais
jason s'est fait la malle ça suffit on
arrête ce plan foireux de gentils
vacances entre amis à la campagne c'est
bien la seule stratégie avec la cage
très d'accord ne va pas s'en aller alors
qu'il est peut-être encore ici tu as
essayé de l'appeler sur son portable il
est resté ici
hé les gars ça veut donc dire qu'il va
revenir
ok écouter les sons passer la nuit en
espérant que jason nous fait seulement
une blague il faut qu'on en soit sûr on
leur cherchera à la lumière du jour
oui d'accord peu importe les biens
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai besoin d'un café je
vous ramène quelque chose merci j'ai
besoin de rien
qui
[Musique]
ne commence l'année
ce tout durée
t'inquiète pas papa
tu appris son art
il ya bien longtemps
[Musique]
tous
hello hello ma belle
c'est quoi ça [ __ ] c'est quoi
qu'est ce que tu as là sur le ventre
regarde
ce sont des points de suture
chirurgicaux belle mais non de dieu
qu'est ce qui se passe ici [ __ ] j'en
sais rien j'en sais rien je vous en prie
on se calme une seconde
comment ça on se calme senna c'est
complètement fou comment veux tu qu'on
se calme jason gann n'est pas réapparu
au courant il est parvenu mec je sais
facture ici ça craint vraiment ok on se
casse d'ici est tout de suite allé
chercher vous d'affaires on se bat k se
donnent des belges mais qu'est ce qui
nous arrive
l'un de vous a vu shannon allait bien
et
car je vais pêcher
stop
lorsque je peux hockey mal barré
grosse surprise il démarre pas
ou le capot font perdre de temps c'est
maintenant original
on est dans la merde les gars t'as
compris ça tout seul
zain ouais c'est qu'il ya plein de
crasse dedans je veux qu'ils soient
analysés
c'est votre boulot de faire ça non ouais
et comparer le haut sans trouver sur la
victime cooper
inspecteur cooper ouais
oui j'aurais bien sûr on pense à k
ok
mais fait bon venir dans quelques heures
quoi est ce que vient de me dire et vous
savez pourquoi parce qu'ils ne
retrouvent pas leurs collègues qui
étaient là hier
pas question que les attentes pendant
des heures c'est non on a cat a
rassemblé nos affaires j'en ai rien à
cirer mes affaires
tu as une idée
les flics vous êtes supposé aider les
gens non quand on vous appelle vous êtes
supposé apporter votre aide
havret
ce
[Musique]
oh
à
[Musique]
oui
au moins on aura essayé
ok allons chercher scott et kristen
écoutons ce qu'en dit si scott kirsten
en fout l'camp tout de suite
ouais ce qu'ils sont c'est bon arrêtez
c'est pas le moment de jouer au hockey
je sais quoi j'appelle scott tendance a
way et les gars montrez-vous [ __ ]
c'est vraiment pas drôle
bell
[Musique]
j'en ai demandé de plus qui m'ont
apporte 4 l'un d'eux est un mois
considérer l'autre comme un cadeau
[Musique]
où est ce que je suis
je crois que
que ça va être difficile de vous
l'expliquer qu'est ce qui s'est passé le
nouveau traitement n'a pas fonctionné
elle a eu une importante réaction morale
est ce que maintenant c'est résolu et
probablement pas non mais ça ne mérite
pas que je m'y attarde
est ce qu'elle peut vous apprendre quoi
que ce soit plus non bien dit aux
internes de ne récupérer une partie de
sa moelle osseuse
mais tout ce qu'ils pourront prélever
d'autres désolé ma chérie tu ne
représente que les pièces de rechange à
mes yeux les pièces de rechange que je
pourrais vendre au plus offrant
il prenait tout ce que vous pouvez
prend les choses comme ceci dis toi que
tu va parcourir le monde
chaque morceau de toit séparément
vous pouvez me les enlever
où sont mes amis
cette fois c'est en soi un boguey
pour ça qu'ils s'y arrêter
côte-d'or la guerre
c'est moi non mais jason qu'est ce que
vous lui avez fait
et
ok
c'est mieux que le premier type plus
costaud on va pouvoir continuer tout de
suite l'entraînement cagoulés le mois
mais
[ __ ] de merde peine tu peux me dire ce
qu'on fait à tâcher là j'en sais rien ou
est-ce qu'on ait ben j'en sais rien sans
tous les autres c'est rien j'en sais
rien je sais foutrement rien j'en sais
exactement autant que toi ok
ah bon
ok
regardez moi
je m'excuse
ça va aller
oui
mais
pourquoi vous me fait de ça à moi je
peux vous raconter une histoire
est ce que je le sois
cette histoire parle d'un petit garçon
un petit garçon totalement innocent son
nom était
non ça n'a aucune importance
ce qui est important
c'est que son père était médecin est en
fait un excellent chirurgien
je n'ai jamais perdu un patient mais il
était maniaque
c'était un perfectionniste son travail
lui tenaient extrêmement à coeur quand
un patient ne réagissez pas bien à une
opération il recommençait la procédure
afin que le rapport de sa prestation
soit parfait je suis prenez comment
c'est là que ça devient troublant il
volait les éléments à transplanter chez
les personnes de son entourage auquel il
avait le plus facilement accès comme
comme sa soeur sa femme il les démonter
pièce par pièce et d'après les médecins
légistes ça a dû prendre un sacré bout
de temps
ça lui a sans doute pris des années pour
disséquer sa femme et le petit garçon il
a disparu pour le gamin
j'imagine qu'il a simplement pris la
fuite
mais hélas il était trop tard le mal
avait bel et bien été fait le petit
garçon grandit il devint un étudiant en
médecine le plus brillant de toute
l'histoire de son école il allait
certainement devenir un merveilleux
chirurgien un chirurgien dans les
compétences égales ray sans aucun doute
celle de son célèbre père mais il avait
au fond de lui un besoin brûlant le mal
qui lui avait été fait cet immense
douleur ne pouvait être soulagé quand
infligeant aux autres ce qu'ils avaient
subi mais ce n'est pas la fin de
l'histoire n'est ce pas alexandre tu
conduiras comptait absolument tout où ça
suffit
comme tu voudras de toute façon et on
vit c'est bien bien trop tordu pour moi
vous n'avez toujours pas fait on ne
devrait pas d'abord le préparer
alexandre l'a déjà fait de plus nous
avons un receveur compatible qui est
prêt qui attend alors allez si prélever
sert à tout de suite vous allez
m'enlever les reins je peux vivre sans
exact dieu que je déteste les parfaits
imbéciles
dès que vous aurez mis ses reins dans la
glace prélevées tout ce que vous pourrez
d'autres sur lui laisser son cerveau il
ne vaut rien vous ne voudrez pas de
meyrin vous savez ne sont pas sains j'ai
toujours beaucoup picoler qu'est ce que
vous faites vous n'allez pas d'abord
m'endormir
finalement il a eu une fille une
splendide petite fille est cette petite
était la lumière de sa vie une semaine
après son sixième anniversaire elle a
développé une maladie mortelle très rare
j'imagine que pour vous ça a dû être
particulièrement douloureux j'ai tout
tenté pour essayer de la soigner
mais sans aucun succès
j'en suis désolé
et
[Musique]
elle et moi
vous allez devoir prendre part à une
expérience destinée à vous entraîner
dans notre métier il nous arrive de
devoir sauver une vie pour ensuite
pouvoir la reprendre l'homme que vous
avez devant les yeux c'est
volontairement mis à la disposition de
la science ils semblent soit en phase
terminale d'une maladie incurable
donc durant les prochains jours votre
priorité sera uniquement de le maintenir
en vie et bien qu attendez vous soigner
sa blessure
oh
[Musique]
je suis bien tranquille
une vertu de la balle surtout rester
laisse moi deviner
thual infecté cette jeune femme avec la
même maladie que celle dont sa fille a
souffert je vous interdit de parler
d'elle jamais
compris c'est très clair oui j'ai
compris alexandre
[Musique]
ou est ce qu'on est
on est dans un hôpital qui est dit
et il faut parle vous êtes sourd
et c'est ce que tahri qu'est ce que vous
avez fait devant meeke rester tranquille
et va mal tenez vous tranquilles
surpris non la douleur va s'atténuer
vous allez voir
tout va bien tout va
ok on va commencer par la moelle et
ensuite on s'occupera des muscles les
tendons et tous les organes qu'on pourra
prélever avant qu'elle n'expire ok on va
la maintenir en vie
oui à ce qu'on nous demande il faut pas
qu'il y ait la moindre des situations et
ses humeurs immédiatement elle dégage
des toxines qui peuvent indiquer l'heure
du décès ce n'est pas ce qu'on attend de
nous c'est la loi de l'offre et la
demande
elle peut laisser au regard des chiffres
est fausse il a d'abord avec les yeux
non veulent pas qu'il y ait de tracer
les drogues dans son organisme
[Applaudissements]
hello dit qu'est ce qu'ils avaient dans
la travée neuze je suis étudiant en
médecine si vous me le dites je
comprendrais dites moi
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il ya de cette [ __ ]
intraveineuse 10e des cuisses et le prix
[Musique]
sale [ __ ]
[ __ ] sa toile ce coup de l'attraper
ce soit dit
qu'est ce qu'ils nous font aller tout le
mois ils ont inoculé une souche de rétro
virus pandémique s'aggrave
oui c'est un virus redoutable j'en ai
déjà entendu parler y'a pas de symptômes
mais c'est pour ça qu'il fait peur à
tout le monde
il ya une brève période d'incubation et
ensuite le virus attaque de plein fouet
des organes se dissolvent et tu crèves
mourir tous les deux est-ce pas il ya
écrit le patient a reçu le traitement
sérologique le patient deux sujets
témoins qu'est ce que ça veut dire
dire que la no 2 est condamné
quelle tenue deux mois moi je suis le
patient ou le patient 2 c'est pas écrit
et c'est peut-être noté la quelle de
12,2 qu'il se jeter mois le cal de 2,2 à
grand mère
[Musique]
je ne voudrais pas déranger ne le fait
pas alors
je constate que tu t'es une fois de plus
laissé aller à un total manque de self
control
j'espère tout de même que tu n'as pas
détruit ce qui m'appartient
pas mal du tout vous avez eu quelques
difficultés mais vous avez réussi à le
tirer d'affaires
ceci dit il est temps d'augmenter
quelque peu l'enjeu est si jamais il
perd conscience vous aurez choisi
[Applaudissements]
vous n'aurez pas sauver le prince et
l'ordre de descendre et fait un garrot
et stopper l'hémorragie
la plupart des gens croient qu'un
traitement ne peut avoir que deux effets
possibles soit ils fonctionnent soit il
ne fonctionne pas mais ils se trompent
parfois le traitement peut être pire que
la maladie
si mal cette fois vous devriez vous
adaptez vous souhaitez changer cette
saloperie
alors venez pas me dire que je devais
m'adapter
non
votre fille
petitement plus sur votre fille
elle s'ennuyait de la maison de temps en
temps quand la douleur devenait trop
intense mais je la retrouvais toujours
et elle rentrait chaque fois avec moi
christelle geste m
qu'est ce thème
carstens
keystone écoute
qui sème
respire
et
[ __ ] merde casse tête
[Musique]
merde
quelle scène
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez maintenu en vie excellent
une passion et un traumatisme organique
majeur
[Musique]
et
jardin
ma
inutile d'insister il est foutu
depuis 50 ans tous tués j'te jure j'ai
entendu ce que je viens de dire je te
ferai la peau salle ap
[Musique]
tu veux
scrat
sopot
ok attend mais s'était tenu le coup je
suis presque
ok ok
tu m'entends au seigneur scott
hu
je
un client
je suis désolé comme si elle n'avait
jamais existé c'est ça
mais enfin tout est ce que ça
ben ali et national
tu vas bien oui t'as vu ta vie de
quartier nantais disons que les cartels
alors tout le monde dit qu'est ce que tu
veux dire que tu donnes sortant d'ici
tout de suite
[Musique]
attends moi je reviens
comment se fait-il que vous soyez sortie
de votre chambre ou mademoiselle
de votre courage et c'est bien là que le
bât blesse voyez vous c'est moi qui
dirige cet établissement vous ne
dirigerait plus longtemps je vais mettre
un terme à votre business
et comment comptez vous vous y prendre
en informant tout le monde de ce que
vous faites ici ça ça m'étonnerait
comment osez vous croire que vous
réussirez à détruire ce que moi j'ai
créé
je travaille au service de ce qui
constitue une violation socio économique
inévitable le sacrifice est nécessaire
c'est l'avenir de l'humanité
mais de quoi est ce que vous parlez en
vain des gagnants et des perdants ma
chère les gagnants peuvent passer
commande et vivre plus longtemps
inspirant à la vie éternelle les
perdants peuvent mourir de façon inutile
ou né et c'est le cas ici en fournissent
à la marchandise
tu avais bien dit que je te tuerais
[Musique]
admettez-le chaque jour vous en entendez
parler même si le monde a choisi de
l'ignorer c'est la simple règle de
l'offre et de la demande
le monde demande et moi j'offre et si je
ne le fais pas quelqu'un d'autre le fera
et c'est là qu'entre en jeu alexandre
tatum une parfaite recrue un mercenaire
chirurgien vous l'avez exploiter ma
chère enfant
personne ne peut exploiter le diable en
personne
tatum et est bien parti pour devenir un
brillant chirurgien mais une fois qu'il
a eu le goût du sang il a perdu de vue
son objectif gelé simplement remis sur
le droit chemin si je puis dire
notre association a toujours bien
fonctionné vous voyez neal a besoin de
sacrifice sanglant pour apaiser ses
démons mais moi j'ai besoin de parties
du corps
malheureusement il perd son temps à
chercher de façon obsessionnelle un
traitement pour une maladie qui
n'affecte chaque année qu'un petit
nombre de personnes dans le monde entier
en quoi cela at il de l'intérêt
hélas il vous a infecté du coup pour moi
vous êtes devenus inutilisables
vous n'avez plus rien à m'offrir
[Musique]
alexandre
plus jamais été dit
tiens bon tiens bon grès avec moi eric
hart thouanel l'esbrouffe
il
c'est une arme à temps j'ai besoin de
reprendre mon souffle
si c'est moi le sujet témoins non si un
kirsten guideurs d'année le traitement
[Musique]
ans
c'est souffrir
nous avons trouvé l'établissement sierre
mais nous n'avons toujours pas retrouvé
alexandre tatum
écoutez il faut que je décroche c'est un
coup de fil que j'attendais mais excusez
moi
étendez les recherches
écoutez ça m'est égal payer leur des
heures sup s'il le faut
ciena
robinson oui monsieur vous savez où elle
est un aide soignant est venue la
chercher pour lui faire passer un test
[Musique]
monsieur l'agent par ici
sinon
c'est maurice et c'est moi tout va bien
écoutez ramener là dans sa chambre et il
ne la quittait pas des yeux c'est
compris
oui monsieur merci ciena tout va bien ça
va les amener avec moi ok rester avec
moi vous inquiétez pas je vais retrouver
tah thomas
ne la quittez pas je compte sur vous à
tous mais ici impossible il ya quatre
entrées et elles sont toutes les quatre
sécurisé à toutes les unités
quel est le topo de la situation
comme je le disais tout est couvert
venez qui va causer
[Musique]
e
qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit sur le tueur
droitiers ou bien cocher gauche et
pourquoi alexandre tatum est droitier
sina porter une blouse de couleur
blanche avec des fleurs roses vous
inquiétez pas
ces toilettes fouillé voulait
à toutes les unités
je suis fait se trouve sans doute encore
dans l'hôpital sécuriser toutes les
sorties
je vais raconter absolument tout
[Musique]
il avait au fond de lui un besoin
brûlant le mal que lui avait été fait
cet immense douleur ne pouvait être
soulagé quand infligeant aux autres ce
qu'ils avaient subi
[Musique]
ok
salida 10 ans forment toujours la
meilleure équipe
qu'est ce qu'il ya
auj
sauf toi
[Musique]
tout va très bien se passer
tout va bien
ne commence jamais ce truc te tuerais
maintenant
dealer comme nous l'avons répété
alexandre dealer
tout va bien
bien se passer et dany tout va bien se
passer
tout va bien
[Musique]
je suis désolé
deneys unités
[Musique]
bon
à
[Musique]